hi i'm katie and today i'm going to be
testing and reviewing the yeti
airfryer oven now the cool thing about
this is it's on oprah's favorite things
of 2020. so today we'll be seeing how
well it works
if the food it makes taste good and if
this is something you should consider
buying yourself we're really going to be
putting this thing to the test by making
some classics first i'll try to make
fried oreos
then some buffalo wings and finally a
blooming onion
all right oprah let's see if your
favorite things are my favorite things
the box is very heavy well it's not very
heavy i'm just very weak the box is a
little heavy
it feels hefty it feels like this it was
expensive heavy things are expensive
yeah yeah generally cars cars
and there's lots to read it's family
size it has an accessory kit it's easy
to use
we'll find out this guy comes with a lot
to offer
oh look at those mini mitts take me a
second
i gotta set this on grab don't film this
everything's okay it's like a little
r2d2 he doesn't do a lot but he just
makes me fried
it's sleek it's pretty and they've
jammed a ton of accessories inside this
guy
bunch of trays buns of baskets where are
the mittens
no oh the mittens are inside i found the
mini mittens
it's a lot of accessories like where are
you gonna store it all in general
everything
feels like it's made of nice metal and
it doesn't feel cheap quality seems good
oh there's so many buttons pizza there's
just a wings button
chicken steak fish shrimp cake we got
all our stuff i'm gonna have to clean up
all this
and then we'll get started on cooking
so to kick things off i'm gonna make
some fried oreos they're feel good
they're nostalgic they're delicious
they're amazing fair
food i'd love to make them at home and
not have my whole house smell like fry
oil the recipe i'm making is one i'd use
for deep fried oreos
but i'm gonna air fry them in the yeti
and then we'll see how it compares
so first thing i'll do i'll make some
milk and an egg
whisk that together always sounds gross
and then i've got a little bit of sugar
and some pancake mix it feels like i
have a little buddy here with me
i don't feel so alone scrape down the
sides of the bowl now before i coat my
oreos i'm going to preheat our air fryer
i'll hit menu to go to manual then i'll
hit temp
timer we'll go up to 350 and then i'll
hit
temp timer again and let's do 10 minutes
for preheating
and we'll hit on and the reason we want
a thick batter is because
we're not putting this in oil so we
don't want it to just
run away all right now it's time to dip
some oreos i got the double stuff kind
because you know
double is better so i'm just kind of
coating this guy
in batter i can't tell you the last time
i had a fried oreo it's been a long time
and then i'm gonna just set him on the
sheet right here
there's no method to this madness last
guy this thing is feeling nice and hot
i'm gonna put them inside
oh a light came off i think i'll just
put him in the middle
wreck it's a little tight i'll leave the
temp at 350 and i'm gonna set the timer
for seven minutes
why'd it go to zero i've hit so many
buttons to make this work
why isn't there an oreo button all right
okay and seven minutes from now we will
see if this yeti can transport us to a
magical state fair where all our
troubles don't exist
we've got less than a minute left and i
get to use my mitts
i'm excited to see how it's going to let
me know that it's done is it going to
play a song
this is just going to be a normal beep
a little underwhelming on the beeping
mechanism all right i guess i'm gonna
turn them off take these guys out oh
okay
interesting the back two got very brown
not golden brown it's too dark and then
this front one didn't really get brown
at all
so i'm a little disappointed about how
uneven the cook was
i'm gonna plate these up and we'll give
them a try putting the ones i don't like
on the bottom
and then i feel like we need to put a
little powdered sugar over the top
just to give it that fair look okay it's
time to give these a try
it's not bad it's a little dry like it's
a little bready
it definitely tastes a little bit like
an oreo wrapped in a pancake but the
oreo was nice and warm
and oozy like a little melty i don't
feel like i'm at the fair unfortunately
i feel like i'm at home and i tried to
be at the fair so i have some deep fried
oreos here to compare
these were cooked in 350 degree oil for
about four to five minutes
that's good but it definitely tastes bad
for you like i'm tasting the oil
these look better they remind me more of
the fair but i
prefer the taste of the air fried ones
actually i actually taste the oreo more
so far my little yeti buddy is off to a
good start next up
buffalo chicken wings
this i think is a very practical test
for our air fryer i feel like when you
make wings at home they're never as
crispy as when you get them at a bar
or restaurant so what i'm really looking
for is if we can get that crisp and i'm
also curious about how much time it's
going gonna take on here it says the
oven it takes about 20 to 22 minutes
i'm gonna hit this wings button and find
out what it says
got our wings i'll spread them out
evenly now it's time to discover
what happens with the wings button oh i
guess it's not a button
you hit menu until it goes to wings
oh which is going to air fry them at 400
for 15 minutes
i don't know if the wings button is for
frozen wings but why not it shouldn't be
these wings are pre-cooked so if it
doesn't cook them all the way it's not
going to be dangerous
so far my expectation is it could work
and in an air fryer
the air is moving around constantly so i
can imagine it cooking it faster
all right the yeti is fired up and we
will be back in 15 to see how it did
all right we have a minute left they're
looking crispy
i believe in this yeti and i want oprah
to be right
i have new myths cause the yeti myths
they couldn't handle the heat
all right it's time to take them out
here's nothing
wings they look pretty crispy
15 minutes that was pretty quick to
finish these off i'm gonna mix them in
the sauce they came with
even the sounds they're making i'm
feeling optimistic they're like crispy
they're sizzling
and i'll toss them i'm gonna plate these
bar style with some celery carrots and a
little blue cheese dressing these are
looking great
better than the bar down the street from
my house i cannot wait to give them a
try
[Music]
and it's hot all the way through and do
you hear that chris
what do you think oprah makes in here
comment below on what you think oprah
makes in this machine
i love wings you gonna wing and you get
a yeti
and you get a yeti and you're gonna get
it these were crisps they were warm all
the way through they were fast
now i'm gonna try some that we baked in
the actual oven and by the way these
oven wings are the same brand everything
is the same
they were just cooked in the oven all
right let's give it a go
[Music]
not as crispy taste wise they're very
similar
but the skin is a lot more chewy i got
to keep it real with you
it definitely makes a difference on the
wings they're much crispier good on you
yeti and good on you oprah
for my next trick we're gonna make a
bloomin onion
up here in this machine a blueberry
onion babel
[Music]
i'm calling this a bloom and onion you
might know it as an awesome blossom
depends on what restaurants you go to
but this thing is epic so
we're gonna try to bring some of that
magic here with the yeti so to start i'm
gonna
cut into quarters at first i'm not
cutting all the way through because we
want it to stay together
and then i'm going to cut those quarters
in half and then i'm going to cut those
in half until we get about 16 slices
once you've made all your cuts you're
going to flip it over and it's going to
bloom like a flower like a rose it's a
rose that will make you cry
not cause it's romantic because it's an
onion i'm gonna season some flour
with a little cayenne pepper some
paprika
some garlic powder oregano a little bit
of salt
and some pepper and you'll whisk that
right up make sure everything
incorporates evenly
next i'm going to take two eggs and some
milk
and we'll whisk that up together i think
oprah's definitely been to outback
steakhouse i think oprah's done
everything she's definitely had a
bloomin onion if she's not oprah hit me
up let's have a blooming onion
so we're going to take our onion and
we're going to put them in our flour i'm
going to do this with my hands
make sure it all gets covered in flour
the goal is to cover as much of the
onion as possible
and then you're going to knock off the
flour then i'm going to set
this in our milk mixture and i'm going
to use one hand to do this
this is messy business so make sure it
gets completely covered
all the insides so i'm going to bring it
back into the flour
i'm just going to toss it one more time
in the flour and so now the flour is
really gonna stick
hopefully this is gonna give us a nice
crispy bloom and onion
i'm gonna put them in the basket wash my
hands and then we'll
put this baby in i got this guy
preheating i'm gonna put this guy
in and then i'm gonna set the timer for
20 minutes
okay so anytime i hit the on button like
sometimes it goes and sometimes it just
resets to zero
sometimes the yeti's got a tude oh
[Music]
we did it and in 20 minutes it's gonna
be a party
[Music]
so i've just checked back in on my onion
there's about eight minutes left
and i'm getting a little worried because
the flour is just looking like flour
like it's looking super dry if this was
being fried
the oil would have helped crisp up that
flour but right now the flour just looks
like
caked on and super dry it doesn't look
good
i have a plan i'm just going to take
some vegetable oil and spray that
on all of my flour the theory here is
that the oil is going to help crisp up
the flour as it bakes so i'm gonna put
it back in
and we'll let it go for the other eight
minutes hopefully that helps
damn it
we're gonna check back in on this in
eight minutes and we'll see what happens
it's almost time all right let's take
him out
okay i definitely think spraying it with
a little oil helped
he looks pretty good he smells delicious
i'm gonna go plate him
and we'll see how he tastes
what okay i'm gonna do it without the
sauce to start
not great it's just the the flour has
really
caked on it and the tips are a little
burnt so i'm getting burnt and then just
like cakey flour
i'm gonna try one dipped in the spicy
horseradish dip
see if that makes it better the answer
is no
let's just compare it to the outback
steakhouse one visually this is so much
better than mine
when you put them together mine looks
really bad mine looks like a nightmare
and this one looks like a really fun
night out
i think my failure is a combination of
things my cutting wasn't thin enough but
i also think the air fryer doesn't allow
it to like open up
as it's cooking you know when you drop
this in like the fryer oil all the
little crevices
like open up to the oil but this one
just sat in that chunky flour
and it just then it burned on the tips
i'm gonna try the outback steakhouse
that is a really good time this is very
good it's crunchy there's nothing burnt
about it
each piece is covered in a little bit of
the batter i don't know
it's just delicious it's super pokable
that is with a pee if you look at mine
like when you take a piece out
it's a huge it's like detaching a finger
this is horrifying
some things you can't make at home and
some things just need to be fried
[Music]
so for the most part it did work pretty
well i like the way the oreos came out i
actually preferred them better to the
fried ones they did a really good job
with frozen food those wings were
excellent
i think it's a great way to level up
your frozen food i think fries would be
good chicken tenders mozzarella sticks
it just gives you that little extra
crisp that's really hard to achieve in
the oven
it's rather big but it doesn't take up
too much counter space it looks sleek
the only issues i ran into were using
the controls sometimes was a little bit
of a hassle and the temperature
and this door gets stuck when you pull
it out
which i guess is good because it's
keeping it airtight in there overall
it's not a perfect conversion when it
comes to fried food
like i preferred the taste of the oreos
but they didn't taste like a fried oreo
and the blooming onion
definitely didn't work but a lot of
foods will work and taste pretty good
so we spent about 150 on this guy would
i buy it for myself
probably not because i really think a
lot of what it can do my oven can do as
well
but if somebody is really into getting
crispy crispy crispy food and maybe
cutting back on their calories
this might be the thing for them air
fryers are super trendy right now and as
far as air fryers go i think this is a
really good one
is this on my favorite things of 2020
list
probably not i'm so sorry oprah let us
know what you guys think in the comments
and if you want to check them out
there's a link below
and thank you guys for watching bye
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]